I think we've mentioned it a little bit
but
I'd like to linger on this question that
uh folk folks like Billy azer yakowski
has to worry about uh and others of the
existential of the serious threats of AI
that have been reinvigorated now with
the rapid developments of AI systems uh
do you worry
about the existential risks of AI as
Eliezer does about the alignment problem
about this getting out of hand
anytime where there's a number of
serious people who are raising a concern
that is that existential
about something that you're involved
with I think you have to think about it
right so
I've spent quite a bit of time thinking
about it from that perspective
um
the thing that I where I basically have
come out on this for now is I I do think
that there are
over time I think that we need to think
about this even more as we as we
approach something that
you know could be closer to Super
intelligence I just think it's pretty
clear to anyone working on these
projects today that we're that we're not
there
um and one of my concerns is that we we
spend a fair amount of time on this
before but
there are more
um
uh I don't know if mundane is the right
word but there's like concerns that
already exist right about like people
using AI tools to do harmful things of
the type that we're already aware
whether you know we talked about fraud
or scams or different things like that
um
and that's going to be a pretty big
set of challenges that the company is
working on this they're going to need to
Grapple with
regardless of whether there is an
existential concern as well at some
point down the road so I I do worry that
to some degree
you can
people can get
a little too focused on
on some of the tail risk and then not do
as good of a job as we need to on the
things that you are can be almost
certain are going to come down the pipe
as um as as real risks that that that
kind of manifest themselves in the near
terms so for me I've spent most of my
time
on that once I I kind of made
the realization that the size of models
that we're talking about now in terms of
what we're building are are quite far
from the super intelligence type
concerns that
um that that people raise but but I
think once we get a couple steps closer
to that
um I know as we do get closer I think
that those you know there are going to
be some novel
um risks and issues about
how we make sure the systems are safe
for sure
I guess here just to take the
conversation in a somewhat different
direction
I think
in some of these debates around safety
I think the concepts of intelligence
and
autonomy or like the the being of the
thing
um you know as an analogy they get kind
of conflated together and
I think it very well could be the case
that you can make something and scale
intelligence quite far
but
that
that may not manifest the safety
concerns that people are saying in the
sense that I mean just if you if you
look at human biology it's like all
right we have our neocortexes we're all
the the thinking happens right and it's
but but it's not really calling the
shots at the end of the day we have a
much more you know primitive
old brain structure for which our
neocortex which is this powerful
Machinery is basically just a kind of
prediction and reasoning engine to help
it kind of like our very simple brain
um
decide
how to plan and do what it needs to do
in order to achieve these like very kind
of basic impulses and
I think that you can think about some of
the
development of intelligence
along the same lines where just like our
neocortex doesn't have free will or
autonomy
um we might develop these wildly
intelligent systems that are you know
much more intelligent than our neocortex
have much more capacity but are you know
the same way that our near cortex is
sort of subservient and is used as a
tool by our our kind of simple impulse
brain it's um you know I think that it's
not out of the question that very
intelligent systems that that have the
capacity to think will will kind of act
as that as sort of an extension of of
the neocortex doing that so I think my
own view is that
where we really need to be careful is on
the development of autonomy and how we
think about that because
um
it's actually the case that
relatively simple and unintelligent
things that have runaway autonomy and
just spread themselves or you know it's
like we have a word for that it's a
virus right it's I mean like it can be
simple computer code that is not
particularly intelligent but just
spreads itself and does a lot of harm
um
you know biologically or computer and
I just think that these are somewhat
separable things and a lot of what I
think we need to develop when people
talk about safety and responsibility is
really the governance on the autonomy
that can be given to to systems and to
me if you know if I were you know a
policy maker is or think about this I
would really want to think about that
distinction between these where I think
building intelligence systems will be
can create a huge advance in terms of
people's quality of life and
productivity growth in the economy
but it's the the autonomy part of this
that I think we really need to make
progress on how to govern these things
responsibly before we
build the capacity for them to make a
lot of decisions on their own or or give
them goals or
things like that and I think that's a
research problem but I do think that to
some degree these are are somewhat are
somewhat separable things I love the
distinction between intelligence and
autonomy and and the metaphor of the
neocortex
let me ask about power
so building super intelligence systems
even if it's not in the near term I
think meta as is one of the few
companies if not the main company that
will develop the super intelligence
system
and you are a man who is at the head of
this company building AGI might make you
the most powerful man in the world do
you worry that that power will corrupt
you
what a question
um
I mean look I think realistically this
gets back to the open source things that
we talked about before which is I don't
think that the world will be best served
by
any small number of organizations
having this
without it being something that is more
broadly available I think if you look
through history
it's when there are these sort of like
unipolar advances and things that in
like power imbalances that they're
they're they're doing to being kind of
weird situations so this is one of the
reasons why I think open sources is is
generally
the right approach and you know I think
it's it's a categorically different
question today when we're not close to
Super intelligence I think there's a
good chance that even once we get closer
to Super intelligence open sourcing
Remains the right approach even though I
think at that point it's a somewhat
different debate
um but I think part of that is that that
is
you know I think one of the best ways to
ensure that the system is as secure and
safe as possible because it's not just
about a lot of people having access to
it it's the scrutiny that that kind of
comes with with building an open source
system right I think this is a pretty
widely accepted thing about open source
is that
um and you have the code out there so
anyone can see the vulnerabilities
um anyone can can kind of mess with it
in different ways people can spin off
their own projects and experiment in a
ton of different ways and the net result
of all of that
is that the systems just get hardened
and get to be a lot safer and more
secure
um so
I think that there's a chance
that that ends up being the way that
this goes to a pretty good chance and
that
having this be open
both leads to a healthier development of
the technology and also leads to a more
balanced
um
distribution of the technology
in a way that that strikes me as good
value is to Aspire to so to you the
risks there's risks to open sourcing but
the benefits outweigh the risks at the
two it's interesting I think the way you
put it
you put it well that there's a different
discussion now than when we get closer
to the uh to development of super
intelligence of of the benefits and
risks of open sourcing yeah and to be
clear I feel quite confident in the
assessment that open sourcing models now
is net positive I think there's a good
argument that in the future it will be
too even as you get closer to Super
intelligence but I've not I've certainly
have not decided on that yet and I think
that it becomes a somewhat more complex
set of questions that I think people
will have time to debate and will also
be informed by what happens between now
and then and to make those decisions we
don't have to necessarily just debate
that in theory right now